These were not the plot holes and goofy
voices you were looking for. Here are
some Jedi mind tricks Star Wars played to alter
fans' memories of the franchise, for the better.
Even after all these years, The Phantom
Menace continues to rank as one of the
lesser entries in the Star Wars saga.
Elements of the film are certainly strong,
with the visuals alone aging remarkably
well in the two decades since its release,
but one noticeably weak aspect of the initial
film is the puppet used to portray Yoda.
As had been the case in the original
trilogy, Yoda was initially featured
on screen through the use of puppetry.
Despite the movie's massive budget, though,
the puppet version of Yoda that appeared in
the first version of The Phantom Menace was
somehow of far worse quality than the one
previously used in Lucas' original trilogy.
Fortunately, Lucas patched this up when it
came time for Attack of the Clones. Realizing
that Yoda would need to physically move around
more in his lightsaber battle with Count Dooku,
Lucas reverted to a CGI iteration of the Jedi
Master, one that would appear throughout the
final two films of the prequel trilogy. To
smooth the continuity between the three films,
he also went back and removed the puppet
version of Yoda from The Phantom Menace,
digitally replacing him with the
CGI version of the character.
One of the most popular changes George
Lucas made to The Empire Strikes Back
was the insertion of Ian McDiarmid's
portrayal of Emperor Palpatine into
the re-released cut of the film. In the
original release, the Emperor briefly
appears in holographic form to converse with
Darth Vader. Voiced by New Zealand stage actor
Clive Revill and physically portrayed
by Marjorie Eaton, this version of the
Emperor looked and sounded nothing like the
Emperor fans later saw in Return of the Jedi.
"The Force is strong with him. The son
of Skywalker must not become a Jedi."
In fact, the design of Palpatine here is often
considered one of the rare flaws within the
original cut of The Empire Strikes Back. When it
came time for Lucas' recut of the film decades
later, he removed this rudimentary version
of Palpatine and replaced it with McDiarmid,
the actor who portrayed Palpatine
across all three Star Wars trilogies.
It's one of the few changes Lucas made to the
original trilogy that fans almost universally
support, improving the Emperor's appearance
in The Empire Strikes Back tenfold. The new
version not only helps link the original
and prequel trilogies together, but also
gives viewers another chance to see McDiarmid
doing his thing — and that's never a bad thing.
One of the cleverer changes made to
Star Wars is a viable explanation
behind the Imperial stormtroopers'
almost impossibly poor aim. Though
Obi-Wan Kenobi describes the stormtroopers
as highly accurate marksmen in A New Hope,
everyone knows that they are anything but. In
fact, the stormtroopers' aim in the original
trilogy is so awful that "stormtrooper
aim" has become more or less the go-to
description when it comes to villains who are
unable to shoot their enemies in films or TV.
In more recent years, Disney has helped provide
a feasible reason why stormtroopers' aims are so
inexplicably bad. In various shows and comics,
it has been established that the Empire began
cutting costs after seizing control of
the galaxy — including slashing military
funding. Unable to afford proper equipment
for its troops, the Empire began outfitting
its soldiers with largely ineffective,
poorly-constructed weapons and armor.
This retcon helps explain why stormtroopers' armor
is essentially useless when it comes
to projectiles or blunt weapons,
as well as why stormtroopers are
unable to hit targets in close range.
Another change made in the remastered
version of The Empire Strikes Back is
the removal of Jason Wingreen's vocal
performance as Boba Fett. While British
actor Jeremy Bulloch wore the armor
of the famous bounty hunter on screen,
Wingreen dubbed Fett's lines with an almost
guttural, Clint Eastwood-esque growl.
"What if he doesn't survive?
He's worth a lot to me."
While certainly intimidating enough, Lucas chose
to replace Wingreen's vocal performance with
Temuera Morrison, the actor who portrayed
Jango Fett in the prequel trilogy. As Boba
himself is a literal clone of Jango, it makes
sense that Lucas would have Morrison voice the
character in the remastered version of The Empire
Strikes Back. Some fans might miss the original,
harshly-delivered snarl of Wingreen's character,
but the switch certainly makes sense in terms
of continuity. Additionally, Lucas inserted
Boba into the 1997 rerelease of A New Hope,
digitally placing him alongside Jabba the Hutt on
Tatooine. It's a minor change, but one that helps
establish Fett's professional relationship
with Jabba early in the original trilogy.
In spite of his incredibly limited screen
time, Boba Fett became a fan-favorite
breakout character after his initial
appearance in The Empire Strikes Back.
When it came time for his return in Return of
the Jedi, however, the character infamously
met an unceremonious and downright goofy end,
falling into the Sarlacc pit early in the film.
Despite seemingly meeting his
death, Fett was hastily restored
to life thanks to a number of "Legends"
comics that expanded on the character,
revealing that he survived his encounter
with the Sarlacc. With Disney's acquisition
of Lucasfilm in 2012, though, all of
these stories were rendered non-canon.
But it was only a matter of time before newer Star
Wars media confirmed Fett's survival, leading to a
number of appearances in The Mandalorian and in
his own spin-off series, The Book of Boba Fett.
Given her prominent role in The Clone Wars,
it's easy to forget that aspiring Sith acolyte
Asajj Ventress actually made her debut in 2003's
underrated Clone Wars animated series by Genndy
Tartakovsky — albeit in a massively reduced
role. In Tartakovsky's series, Ventress appears
as a one-off Force-wielder recruited by Count
Dooku to assassinate Anakin Skywalker. Dueling
the Jedi in the jungles of Yavin 4, Ventress
tests Anakin's physical and emotional limits,
narrowly beating him before a rage-filled
Anakin sends her hurtling to her death.
In the 2008 Clone Wars computer-animated film,
a different version of Ventress appears in a
more expanded role, as an antagonist to
the Jedi and a commander of the Separatist
Army. While initially similar in nature
to the original version of the character,
Ventress would become more fully fleshed
out as The Clone Wars went on, receiving
her own backstory and eventual redemption arc
after she is betrayed by her former master,
Dooku. Before long, Ventress became one of the
key players in the latter-day Clone Wars series,
with many fans seeing her as one
of the show's best characters.
One of the earliest and most glaringly obvious
plot holes in 1977's Star Wars was how the
Empire overlooked such a crucial flaw in the
Death Star plans as its critical exhaust port.
"The target area is only two meters wide. It's a
small thermal exhaust port,
right below the main port."
As seen in the movie, all the Rebels
need to do is launch one proton torpedo
into the port in order to destroy
the entire battle station. It's an
oversight on the Empire's part that leads
directly to the Death Star's destruction,
leaving many wondering how they could
possibly miss such a devastating weakness.
With the release of Rogue One nearly four decades
later, however, it's established that the exhaust
port was actually put there on purpose by Galen
Erso. Forced to build the Death Star by Orson
Krennic and knowing the devastating effect
it will have on the galaxy, Erso designed
the Death Star with one crucial weakness that
the Empire's enemies will be able to exploit.
Showing Erso's efforts to sabotage the station
through the exhaust port was an effortless way
of clearing up confusion around one of the
original trilogy's most questionable plot
points. It also makes the ending of
A New Hope that much more satisfying,
knowing the crucial part that Erso — and his
daughter — played in the Death Star's destruction.
A chief complaint fans had regarding
The Phantom Menace was the sudden and
surprising death of Darth Maul. Possessing
few lines and a very limited screen presence,
Maul was nevertheless seen as a villain
with enough visual appeal and menace to
rival Darth Vader. As such, many believed he
might fill a role similar to Vader's in the
prequel trilogy. When he met his abrupt
end in the climactic duel with Obi-Wan,
however, some audience members saw his
early demise as a wasted opportunity.
Knowing fans' love for the Sith warrior, Lucas
made the decision to revive Maul in The Clone
Wars. In the show, it's explained that Maul
miraculously survived his maiming at Obi-Wan's
hands, although he was left physically and
mentally broken by the ordeal. When his brother,
Savage Opress, rescues him from a junk
planet he'd been stranded on for a decade,
he helps restore Maul's mind. Fully
restored, Maul leads his brother in
forging a new criminal empire in the galaxy,
becoming a perpetual thorn in the Jedi's side.
The decision to reverse Maul's death was
a welcome one in the eyes of longtime Star
Wars fans. Maul's expanded role in The
Clone Wars and Rebels has been praised
as one of the highlights of both shows,
helping expand the character and take
advantage of his unique chemistry
with the show's other characters.
"Execute Order 66."
One of the hardest things George Lucas
and Dave Filoni had to explain in The
Clone Wars was how the clone troopers could
so easily turn on their Jedi commanders. As
shown in the series, the clones are usually
close friends and confidantes to the Jedi,
bonding with them throughout the
war. This makes their dramatic
shift in personality during Order 66
that much more difficult to believe.
Nevertheless, Lucas and Filoni came up
with an ingenious idea that provided a
feasible explanation behind the clones'
sudden betrayal. In the prequel trilogy,
the clones' nonchalant massacre of the Jedi
is done of their own volition. The clones
seem to genuinely believe Palpatine's
lie that the Jedi are taking over,
choosing to remain loyal to the Chancellor
and the Republic over the Jedi conspirators.
However, this would later be retconned in the
final few seasons of The Clone Wars, with the
show revealing that nearly every clone trooper is
implanted with a behavioral modification biochip
that effectively controls their thoughts and
emotions. When activated, they essentially become
sleeper agents, instilling them with dramatically
high aggression against their Jedi comrades.
Arguably one of the best retcons made in The
Clone Wars, the biochips explain the sudden
shift in personality among the clones, and
helps portray them in a new, tragic light.
One of the biggest changes made to the
Star Wars universe was the introduction
of Ahsoka Tano in The Clone Wars. Although she
doesn't appear in any of the prequel movies,
Lucas and Filoni did a wonderful job
interweaving the character's narrative
into the overall universe of the prequels.
Over time, Ahsoka would become one of the
most beloved characters in the entire Star
Wars canon, her popularity directly leading
to appearances in other shows, including
her own spin-off series on Disney+.
Aside from her frequent appearances following The
Clone Wars, Ahsoka also allowed a more layered
exploration of Anakin's character. Gradually
learning to become a more mature master to Ahsoka,
Anakin was finally able to realize the burden of
having a pupil study under him. The Jedi Order's
poor treatment of Ahsoka also provided
an additional reason for his frustrations
with the Jedi in Revenge of the Sith, helping
shed more light on his turn to the Dark Side.
It's up for debate whether George Lucas
had a complete vision for the original
trilogy in his mind while working on Star
Wars in the mid-1970s. There are certainly
some issues with the canon that support
the idea that Lucas was still planning
out the story as he developed the second
installment of the original trilogy. The
most obvious among these issues would be
the reveal that Leia and Luke are siblings,
and the revelation that Darth Vader is
the father of the two long-lost twins.
In early drafts of The Empire Strikes Back,
Vader appears as a separate character from
Anakin Skywalker, who appears as a Force ghost
to Luke on Dagobah. In that scene, Anakin's ghost
reveals to Luke that he has a sister, although
he refuses to share any further information
for fear of Darth Vader finding out about her.
The fact that Anakin and Vader are two separate
characters falls in line with Obi-Wan telling
Luke in A New Hope that Vader killed Anakin.
"He betrayed and murdered your father."
In this rough draft of the script,
Luke's sister is called Nellith,
and it seems that she is meant to be a
separate character from Leia. Luckily,
Lucas would decide to tweak both of these
decisions, turning Leia into Luke's sister
and making Vader their father — resulting in one
of the greatest plot twists in cinematic history.